ok ich bitte sie ganz herzlich zu diesem
seminar ins sommersemester formen des um
ein neues thema ich glaube so ein thema
gab es bisher noch nicht
es gibt viele sogar das böse herr bin
noch nicht ganz unschuldig aber form
eines moralisch ein solches gab es laut
nicht manchmal verwirrt einen zarten
seien bestimmt gesehen dass ich ein
bisschen um gewerke papier steht mit
kamera also das ganze wird jetzt
aufgenommen hat und von mir getrennt
wissen wenn sie sich melden sind sie
total was ich ihnen sagen ist ein garten
schutz gründe gibt es nicht aber sie
müssen wissen dass mit aufgenommen dass
es zu ihrem vorteil weiß
da brauche ich mal nachsehen können da
nicht weiter drüber sagen
jetzt hat der kommilitone ganz vorne
schon gesehen dass ich da ein programm
habe mit dem man auch live streams
realisieren kann jetzt ist die frage
ich bin noch ein seminar diesem semester
an zum thema philosophie der digitalität
da geht es um technische aspekte wie
anders als heute diesen jetzt sollte
meine frage wollen sie dass ich dieses
seminar auch live stream auf youtube
oder wollte ist er nicht also ich denke
weil dieses kontaktes seminar ein
bisschen mehr ich sagen kontrovers ist
hatte ich jetzt gedacht wir machen jetzt
erstmal nicht sein aber ich gibt es dann
an sie zurück also wer möchte ist live
gestreamt tagen einfach mal melden
okay wer möchte das nicht läuft das
stimmt und die anderen ist dem ist egal
ok dann maria es ab nächste sitzung auch
inline vertagung das heißt sie kann auch
dann live mit schiffen also es gibt also
einem chat bereich und wenn sie das
gefühl haben sie ich nehme sie nicht
dran denn immer dieselbe person
dann schreiben sie an das rein hallo ich
habe da noch eine frage und ich hab dann
hier so ein tablet und liest es dann
gehen wir also was sie da schreiben
hier kann jeder sich auf seine weise
dran
also die heutige sitzung ist dann nicht
live aber die wird auch das internet
bestimmt dass nur zum technischen ich
komme nachher nochmal ein bisschen
genauer trend zu sprechen
ok beginnen wir mit diesem wert indessen
einige maßen sie und ich möchte sie
fragen sich das irgendwann ein bisschen
anpassen kunden
studieren sie ist ein bisschen und sagen
mir dann was sie auf diesem bild zu
erkennen glauben und was das wasser zu
im glauben mit diesem seminar zu tun hat
für die lakers also was könnte das was
könnte es sich dabei handeln gezwungen
auch die schweden haben wissen sie
vielleicht gar kirchenmaler dieses bild
ist dadurch bekannte maler
ich habe aus dem 16 15
überlegen sie mal bronze
gehen sie mal ganz kurz mit ihrem
nachbar mit nach bremen reden sich mal
ganz kurz beim laufen fast halten ist
oder anders gefragt wie ich form des
unmoralischen hier abgebildet sein
können wir fahren wenn sie glauben dass
es eine bestimmte form des
begründen sie mal mit verweisen auf
eingeteilt
hier sehen was es sein könnte ich hab'
ich warte noch ein kleines bisschen ich
hab sie gesehen was passieren sie sich
gerne mit ihrer einsätze aus damit
möchte ich einfach mal ein bisschen
sammeln was sie glauben was ich mir okay
da hat sich jetzt schon eine gewählte
bitte hier
das ist definitiv keines sieht man sieht
es auch diesmal ein paar mal weiß ich
geldpolitik sondern auch zwischen weil
das land unter in mitte aber jetzt also
ein lateinisches
ja gut genau sie habe auch gelesen also
das ist wahrscheinlich geld was sie da
also man einsammelte haben sie noch
weitere bemerkungen eintrag
beobachtungen jahreshälfte lebens zu
sehen sie zumindest würde ich so schätze
etwas höher sondern auch mehr ins bild
dass möglicherweise im himmel auch
rechts mit den rostschutz auch im krieg
geht es auch um gründern sehe es auch
weiter unten links hier da wir das hier
hat es sehr schwierig und requiriert
aktiviert als rasenmäher hat besonders
gut gefallen
diese wie die damit der baum musste auf
diese pilzart geld zuschießen dann fehlt
das geld hier sind also das können sie
mal ein anderes studieren das ist eine
allegorie der allegorie auf eine form
des buch und weil es so schön war gleich
nochmal 1 dann schauen sie doch mal auch
noch mal alles denken kannst
sehen diskutieren sie mit ihrem wagen
sitzen dafür sich was sie glaube das
darf eine form des mastes abgebildet ist
in der symbolisch beständigkeit lebens
sie können schon ein bisschen lesen wenn
sie solche schauen dass wir statt und
bringt sie sogar das noch kleinere
kursiv gedruckt lesen können dann das
durch niederländisch glaube ich hatte
freunde sind wieder
dann können sie das auch noch ein
bisschen weiter schließt auch das kann
man glauben nicht ganz so gut sehen
ich glaube ich kann sogar ein wort
verstehen was auch wieder in der stadt
aber ich glaube wir haben jetzt ein
bisschen zeit gerne einfach mal zu
sammeln
sagen sie einfach was ich hier gesehen
habe was das für einen last oder eine
form des überrascht sein
ja genau
und das ist wichtiger punkt weil hier
stehen geschafft und könnte mehr drehen
können viele und was sonst noch
hier wird irgend etwas nie wieder
passieren sie dass hier hier dieses
gebäude das personalisierung als ganz
offen heißt sie auch nicht aber man
könnte sich was überlegen mich wirkt das
sowieso ein großer kessel besonders gut
ankam
[Musik]
damit was gebraten hier haben sie hier
bei der großen pfanne mit viel rauch was
könnte es ja genau
es geht in diese richtung für noch ein
ich hab dann natürlich sofort ans
oktoberfest gedacht und wenn man das
jetzt so sieht ist eine vielleicht eine
der todsünden da muss man auch mal
genauer betrachtet es gibt ja diese
truhe zünden die dann auch allegorisch
immer wieder im mittelalter noch ein
ausgang des mittelalters illustriert
wurden und ich finde ganz spannend aber
so ganz spontan jetzt dass gewisse
lasten
diese eigenschaften oder einstellungen
die früher kann es sehr tun teil und
acht galt moralisch gehalten dass man
sich gegenüber den heutzutage in die
verwenden wir nicht ganz sogar in
manchen phasen sogar sehr positiv
gegenüber verhält
wir müssen immer auch schauen wie sich
so ein wandel vollzogen aber auf jeden
fall finde es sehr eindrucksvoll und das
soll vorbei der ausgang dieser sitzung
sei
dann haben wir sogar noch eins ist das
jetzt guter letzt
sehen sie hier
ja genau faulheit oder was noch einen
verwandten sword werden sie sagen zu
überlegen sind katalog der erlass tag
würde man sagen ja faulheit oder was
gibts nur trägheit gemacht trägheit und
hier steht auch auf niederländisch trägt
man sieht mir glaube ich sehr gut was
ist dass sie so der integrierte
allegorische inbegriff der trägheit
sehen sie da irgendwas was besonders
verbieten würden ja die schnecke hier
doch dieses wesen hat nicht alle im
prinzip ist krieg hier wird jemand
gezogen auch versteht nicht besonders
schnell rezession wird seltsames lesen
was wenn sie genau hinschauen ob so
einfluss hat oder so ein stab hat als es
kann gar nicht schnell vorankommen das
muss doch gehen können und hier liegt
jemand drin und design umfassen krank
und dreht und hat nichts anderes zu tun
als eben langsam die vorträge befassen
sich fortbewegen
auch noch etwas zu essen zu bekommen von
einem seltsamen wesen das ist assistiert
das gab auch schon was wir sonst noch
einfällt also damit natürlich noch eine
frau auf einem esel glaube ich und ich
glaube dass diese these years nicht an
der lesung ist ja auch geld ja auch ist
ein lebewesen weiß jetzt es nicht
besonders eilig haben dass ein bisschen
störrisch ist bisschen dumme ist dass
hingeben
dieses sieht aus wie das so langsam vom
sprung bekommt da werde ich nicht ganz
schlau hier sehen sie noch personen
morsum ziffernblatt mit dem arm der
anzeige dient und der die zeit
wahrscheinlich zeit wieder sinnlos
verstreicht veranschaulicht center
beträgt ist also hier können sich dann
aber ein bisschen genau hinein vertiefen
das sind jedenfalls ein paar formen des
unmoralischen die jetzt auf den ersten
blick gar nicht so schlimm drücken auf
das sie kennen bestimmt auch das lob der
faulheit ins team das heißt so
oder dass man ein bisschen träge angehen
lassen
da muss sollte das ist unmoralisch sein
als wir müssen es auch mal ein bisschen
problematisieren aber das sind ebenfalls
eher eine eindrucksvolle darstellung
gewissen formlos unter deutschen und
jetzt kann man fragen darum sollten uns
überhaupt mit dem umfeld befassen
darum setzen wir überhaupt hier im
seminar und schaue ich solche bilder an
die von etwas zeuge was doch besser
nicht sein
zurück wobei oktoberfest anfassen und
sorgt das wirklich strenge schlagen
gewissen grenzen ist doch okay
sicherlich aber warum sollte uns zu
denken damit belassen
andere fragen ist das unmoralische
überhaupt philosophisch begrifflich
analysierte haben wurde entzieht sich
nicht der fall
das finde ich schon interessanter also
dasjenige was schlecht ist das böse ist
was nicht sein soll
wie können wir das positiv weiter
überhaupt bestimmen und damit verbunden
die alles entscheiden entscheiden
vielleicht können wir gerade durch
analysen des unmoralischen das moralisch
gute besser verstehen
das ist und sie meine these ist nicht
meine eigene these nur das haben auch
schon andere lenker und lenkerinnen
vertretung gibt es interessantes buch
von art voll mit dass es nachher umgehen
mit dem titel unmoral das kennt der eine
der andere schon und der wirt macht auch
die these dass es sich als lohnt sich
mit dem ungewaschen fassen beide dadurch
das nomadische besser verstehen und er
hat ja sogar ein ganzes handbuch des
unmoralischen verfasst von ausbeutung
bislang hat das noch einmal gut gehen
werden das sind so fragen die ich hier
was beginn an zu fuß ins plenum geben
möchte und bei andere fragen da jetzt
ein bisschen genauer an wie verhält sich
das böse zum moralischen ich habe ein
paar seminare hier schon angegeben immer
über das böse und luxuswagen jahr machen
sich gleich nochmals sie mit das böse
wort unmoralisch glückstag unterschied
man könnte sich jetzt zum beispiel
denken dass das böse
eine besondere form des unmoralischen
ist nämlich dass alle ungewöhnlichste
was es gibt
so könnte man sich das vorstellt man
könnte aber auch sagen heim das böse ist
die kategorie das ist das schreckliche
das grausame das steigere das nicht und
das normale wasser im mittleren bereich
auch ein täglich 91 vollzieht man kann
am 12
theorie ist natürlich unterscheiden kann
es sagen es damit kontinuität these dass
das böse groß und quantitativen wie
qualitativen steigerung des überraschend
ist oder man kann für sie mit differenz
cs argumentieren dass beide das böse um
das unmoralische strikt voneinander
unterschieden wird auch immer so ein
bisschen mehr einbringt die aber dass
sie keineswegs bindend seien zwar ich
glaube dass es eine kontinuität ist dann
das inzwischen gemüse die homepage zu
spenden können das ist eine graduelle
komplexität anreichert ist die dann vom
analog zum wirklich gestört und dass das
was spezielles ist das aber ich kann
schon andere thesen vertreten da bin ich
ganz offen
diese systematischen fragen die ich
jetzt gleich noch ein bisschen weiter
erklären wird
dies sollten wir zusammen immer im
hinterkopf behalten wenn wir uns dann
mit den verschiedenen formen des
englischen befassen weitere frage ist
welche form des humors erlebt was gehört
dazu was nicht wenn wir sind einfach das
was im orange dieses mitleid
wie ist es nicht
[Musik]
was gehört überhaupt dazu ist das
überhaupt objektiv bestimmbar könne es
aber auch objektiv erklären oder ist das
ein bisschen bargeld
worin liegt er kennt im moralischen
handelns warum handeln wir überhaupt
moralisch und was genau ist ein
unmoralisch ist es unsere handlung ist
unser wie lebenseinstellung charakter
oder ist es sogar eine person die wir
uns schnell gibt es böse und ungewaschen
menschen wenn sie sich zum beispiel
manche filme anschauen kinofilmen dann
super das suggeriert dass es böse
menschen leben
sie kennen alle hannibal lecter weil
diese das ist der bösewicht dem es gibt
laut umfragen sagen das ist der
inbegriff des bösen
und wenn sie sich mal an die ba legte
anschauen
in schweigen der lämmer dann werden sie
feststellen der hannibal ist sieht gar
nicht so böse aber er hat etwas
unheimliches ansicht des gerichts zu
aber wenn sie dann sehen wir dann das
wohltemperierte klavier von bar in
seiner zehnten wird und total also total
investiert da auch kommuniziert
offensichtlich sehr intelligent ist dann
haben wir es hier mit einem phänomen zu
tun was nicht auf den ersten
als solches als blöde uno mission zu
klassifizieren ist man dann sehen wir
das ganze ist ganz schön komplex also
das unmoralische das böse das hat es mit
intelligenz zu tun da kommt plötzlich
noch kreativität ins spiel
und das macht das ganze phänomen zum
spannung wie persönlich sagen ich bin
skeptisch dass es sowas wie bösen person
gibt unmoralische menschen persönlich
glaubt es nicht aber es gibt bestimmt
aber darüber können wir diskutieren das
ist auch in der forschung stritten
darüber immer sehr gerne weiter reden
glaube das nicht haben er glaube jeder
mensch hat immer die möglichkeit immer
wieder zu ändern
es gibt phasenweise verstrickungen in
denen jemand vielleicht ziel sind nur an
der spitze und da auch gar nicht mehr
rauskommt aus diesem gedanken system
aber ich würde es nicht als das
essenziell ist isches indizien ein böses
erlöses wesen in bösen menschen als zu
richten gibt er auch als gemüse auf die
welt gekommen ist das glaube ich nicht
habe mir können darüber reden und dann
eben noch mal diese vor gibt es eine
qualitative skala des omanischen also
der arendt vollmann in seinem buch über
das unmoralisch
der zählte die ganze last auf bvb tisch
was wir uns auch noch daneben fragen
wollen ist erstmal die vollständigkeit
also was gehört dazu was nicht es ist
das vollständig und haben wir manche
phänomene außer acht gelassen und dann
wollen wir unsere
fragen wie verhalten sich diese laster
zueinander also missioniert
beziehungsgefüge des normativen also wie
unmoralisch genauso qualität ist sind
diese form und wie können wir sie in
eine art angefordert
das ist das allerbeste und warum und was
vielleicht am unteren ende
also wir wollen hier sonne warum gründen
wir müssen gründe dafür geben dass wir
eine form erreicht als moralischer
gegenüber eine andere form kann ich
jetzt müssen die gründe dass die
kriterien die sekretärin wollen wir hier
auch immer reflektieren als auch immer
den begriff des moralischen
gegebenenfalls den verbänden lösen
kritisch betrachten warum weil solche
begriffe wie böse oder auch lasterhaften
jugendhaft weil das ganz stark
formativ begriffe sind
auch menschen mit der handlungen ihre
intentionen disqualifizieren ein
schlechtes licht rücken
wie bewerten sie hier
wir tun damit was ist eigentlich so dass
wir damit möglichkeiten die wir als
solche begriffe wie böse oder
unmoralische wenden sondern wir tun
damit wir stellen damit diese pragmatik
das buch ist ja nicht dass noch was
beschreiben das ist an einem beschreiben
tun wir etwas mit dieser person auf die
wir solche begriffe abziehen
man muss natürlich aufpassen weil wir
können natürlich auch manchmal menschen
einfach nur ins gewissen
interessensgruppen disqualifizieren
dafür böse dies böse der ist sowieso
kein wir müssen aufpassen solche
begriffe zu verwenden anzuhäufen wird
die welt wie sie alle wissen in schwarz
und weiß in der achse des guten
eine teilnahme ist natürlich aufpassen
sollte nicht allzu voreilig solche
begriffe leichtfertig verwenden den
begriff des bösen kann aber auch wie ich
meine solch eine form des omanischen das
kanton bisschen den anlass sein
da muss man immer auch ein bisschen
vorsichtig sein ich sagte dass schon der
begriff des bösen jedenfalls mit dem ich
mich jetzt sehr beschäftigt habe und ob
es die nase folgere nagel die er ist
umstritten ein versuch mit dem land für
den kopf sagt dass wir hier auf e mail
regionaler vorsorgekonzept surfen den
badischen software-tool religious und
wieder sind wir für lau zu beherrschen
road played the world of the other
chelsea also das abitur ein begriff der
in großen erzählungen noch eine rolle
spielt zum beispiel in hollywood filmen
was aber der eigentlich auf diese welt
auf die wirkliche welt bezogen keine
rolle mehr spiele deswegen nimmt der
außerdem müssten die mittel sind die
einzel anderen verwendet macht
den feind zu dämonisieren und die haben
es vielleicht bei harry potter noch mit
dem bösen zu tun oder nicht weißen gegen
zur frauen- oder sowas war nicht mehr in
der wirklichen welt das disney these die
sehr viele vertreten ich mir gerade sie
zurück fragen einfach mal mehr wer
glaubt dass der begriff des bösen wie es
korrekt dass der nur ein mit logisches
konzept ist dass er keine wohnung des
spiels wird unsere heutige wird einer
dieser mann und wissen ja dürfte das
gerät und richtig gut sind die werkzeuge
minderheit 33 haben sie jetzt meldet das
ist auch eine völlig legitim
also da ist dessen bedenken damit und
das müssen wir ernst nehmen dass wir
dürfen nicht alles so leid für die
verwendung sollten
natürlich hat die mehrheit haben jetzt
gesagt er ist doch irgendwie sinnvoll
sonst wäre es ja nicht jedem seminar
aber dürfen natürlich sehr gerne immer
es ist sehr wichtig diese begriffe
problematisieren zb kann man dem
sinnlosigkeit einbringen und sagen
dieser begriff ist sinnlos des
bedeutungslos der begriff sagen was über
uns aus und über unsere machtinteresse
so wurde zb friedrich nietzsche aus
mädchen würde sagen also eher die
genealogie der moral ist weil ich kennen
sie dieses werk für franchise
jetzt hat also gute böse sind
erfindungen der sklaven damit wir damit
die schwächeren mit dem schrecken ein
schlechtes gewissen machen und dann ist
da das dabei ist das dann also ganz von
der hand zu weisen ist dieser einwand
nicht
ich glaube ich persönlich glaube dennoch
ist der begriff sinnvoll ist aber ein
bisschen problematisieren und jetzt sagt
ein anderer philosoph otfried höffe als
20 jahrhundert ist an der höchstform
menschliche verantwortete schlechtigkeit
den bösen überreicht ein philosophischer
reflexion darüber mit den arten davon
aber da ist was dran ist
er sagt jetzt es gibt das böse haben
auch den zweiten weltkrieg und die
ganzen großen ideologien denke die daten
lesen getrieben haben
aber es gibt zu wenig reflexion darauf
sogar die zweite hälfte des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts ist eigentlich dominiert in
der ethik durch sogenannte die
sogenannte magic also mächtig sagt nur
was darüber aus wie wir moralisch
aktiver verwenden
das bedeutet aber nicht ob sie wirklich
auf die welt anzuwenden sind
als die mutter wenig befasst sich nun
mit dem begrifflichen bereich und ich
mit der frage nach den anwender hat auch
tatsächliche phänomen das hat sich in
der jüngsten zeit also ein bewusstsein
20 ergeben dass man sich auch
tatsächlich fragen ob diese beliefen
sich doch auf die welt angewendet werden
können also das gibt jetzt schon ein
halbes jahrhundert ein halbes
jahrhundert musste wirklich für
diejenigen sogar noch ein bisschen mehr
bis man endlich auch in der philosophie
sich diesen themen wieder eine kritische
weise an
warum haben wir wollen wir verstehen uns
in diesem seminar in dieser tradition
stehen die diese begriffe nicht nur mit
spitzen fingern anfassen sondern die
sich mit ihm regiert philosophisch
auseinandersetzen wollen auch dass alle
kritik den man diesen kritischen
einstellung die man diesen begriffen
gegenüber aufweisen muss
so und jetzt zähle ich immer so ein paar
formen das irgendwo war nicht auf und
sie können sich jetzt überlegen ob da
hier vor ort das guck mal schon durch
die verliert und das sind aber diese
besonders interessant finden auf die
damit dabei ist weil das ist jetzt auf
unser seminar bleibt dabei offen dass
sie da weitere vorschläge bringen wir
sammeln die dann werden hier in einer
sitzung werden die sieben todsünden
ich finde die sollten anfang stehen das
ist so die kämpferin films zellen
erkennen für uns zählen winkelmann es
aber hier ein bisschen anschauen und ein
bisschen besprechen wenn sie wollen
da geht es diese todsünden die da
gerecht werden und die lehrende hatte
sehr grausam
dieser veranschaulicht wir können
vielleicht morgen dass die angewandte
szenen anschauen muss man schauen ob das
rechtlich überhaupt
wir brauchen uns auch nicht die grausame
szenen anschauen sollen wir können
einfach ein bisschen drüber diskutieren
das sollten wir glaube ich mal
vorstellen der nächsten sitzung jemand
darauf ein bisschen heim und auch diese
ganze bilder dieses allegorien geht sie
da gesehen haben die werden wir auch im
nächsten der nächsten sitzung behandeln
wir wollen schauen wir diese des
unmoralischen allegorisch bilde
künstlerisch verhandelt das finde ich
besser machen also damit muss man ihm
sagt dass wenn man sich mit dem
unmoralischen beschäftigt kommt man so
vorhinein interdisziplinären diskurs
eines unerwartet ich eben nicht nur aus
philosophischer sicht von bedeutung
sondern auf jeden fall wenn man sie mit
den sieben tore aus theologischer sicht
ganz wichtig also theologie und
philosophie sind die zweite problem die
sich besonders mit diesem thema was wir
machen lassen aber natürlich aber die
ästhetik also bildende kunst und
naturwissenschaft die musik das ist ein
wichtiger grund wird auch die sünde bern
wie zb mitwirken kann
die waren so etwas dabei das kann man
also sehen dass auch die tontechnik
gewisse form des unmoralischen ausdruck
finden zb kennen sie den tritonus diesen
diesen klang in diesen akkorden
tritonus der wird ein system der diabolo
ist das ist eine figur die eben in ganz
besonderen musikalischen situationen
eingesetzt wird um das böse oder orange
zu bezeichnen eine disharmonie die die
ganze musikalische tonale struktur
durcheinanderbringt und nichts anderes
meinte auch teufel teufel diabolos meint
einfach nur derjenige der zerwürfnis
stiftet der das ganze durcheinander
bringt das mal nicht läuft dann die
lücke das ist ein interessanter kandidat
ich finde die lüge ist mein favorit
haben meine favoritin unter dem formen
des moralischen wenn sie mal in die
bibel schauen die sündenfall geschichten
hat ja da kommen auch schon gewisse
formen vorher ist die lüge dass es war
auch andere form des ungarn oder schon
vorhanden denn alt finde ich auch ganz
spannend undankbarkeit diskriminierung
jetzt wird's ein bisschen politische
rache egoismus moralismus außerdem
favorit von mir moralismus weil der
organismus ist eine form des humors
hat jemand so als sei er dem moralisch
ist aber im behauptung der mobilität
gerade im ort als wird die mobilität
selbst pervertiert dann die
instrumentalisierung sie kennen alle von
immanuel kant dieses gebot dass man den
anderen nicht nur als mittel zum zweck
haben immer als selbstzweck auch sollte
den anderen als nur ein bloßes mittel
zum zweck der handel dann kommt
natürlich das thema kapitalismus ein
bisschen rein ich möchte mit
kapitalismuskritik ins zentrum stellt
aber in die moderne arbeitsteilung die
funktionale differenzierung weder es nur
ein kleines rädchen träge und ich frage
ist das moralisch und rassismus und
antisemitismus
ich habe die jetzt ergriffen dann kann
auch andere formen mit für die sehr
philosophisch interessant und
terrorismus und fanatismus aktuelles
phänomen und wollte und tierquälerei
denke ich kümmer auch noch mit meinen
geschmack
jetzt wollte ich sie fragen ob sie hier
noch formen des moralischen vermisst
hatten vermissen die wir hier noch mit
war aufnehmen
sollten sie können sich das ja noch
überlegen wir sie können wir uns auch
schreiben oder wenn sie jetzt noch was
haben ja
ok sexualität in diesem bereich 6 wurde
wirkt also wobei sexualität ja nichts
unreines liegt langsam eine sonder so
eine form von sexualität die so ein
bisschen pervertiert ist wobei man
natürlich heute sehe wie soll ich sagen
das ist ein heikles thema aber ich nehme
es mir auf ich bin es spannend also
formen der sexualität wirklich
unmoralisch sind
[Musik]
dieser ist moralische
wir müssen
ja also ich es ist ein wichtiger punkt
das geht ja auch ein bisschen die
richtung die man vielleicht also ich
habe noch auf das thema auf jeden fall
auf dem schirm
ich bin dankbar dass dieses thema
missachtung und ich sage jetzt mal hier
tabus
vielleicht auch weil das alles damit ich
hoffe dass das problem des respekts dass
wir jemanden nicht respekt
entgegenbringen ist eigentlich sollten
ja ja wichtig genau
das weiß nicht nur interessiert
historische und das hat auch mit liebe
zu tun
täuschung und selbsttäuschung wobei die
frage ist ist man woran man sich ein
selbst gestellt ist kann man nicht mit
sich selbst tun das gibt uns
sie haben glaube ich so richtig vom
netzteil ist wird philipp otto lorenz
geredet aber über intoleranz und
vielleicht auch für geräte aber niemand
ist eigentlich so ganz genau darüber
klar dass intoleranz 1 und meinten sie
dass so ein bisschen mitgenommen
ich glaube dass man also meine these ist
sie meine absicht war nicht das seminar
gäbe wäre am ende viel mehr über die
positiven formen wenn wir uns über ihre
effizienz formen oder über den negativen
formel diskutieren wir darüber dass
mädchen und ich denke vielleicht eine
kleine punkte mir jetzt kommt dass sie
immer letztendlich para begriffen also
das sollten wir auch mal berücksichtigen
das ist immer die falsche form einer
eigentlich guten form
es ist die und das ist die perversionen
das ist die defizitäre form darüber
müssen wir noch genauer reden einer
eigentlich moralischen form als zb
verachtung was wäre da das der
gegenbegriff dazu das wäre das wichtig
ist angebracht und genau die lachen oder
der respekt ist
und er respektiert
und untreue ist gerade zu wehren und
intolerant ist die toleranz und sie
sehen wir haben jetzt hier manchmal alte
losung privatier form als affäre mit ihm
sind die ganzen kinder haben werden der
kampanischen vorn hat ist es eigentlich
nur eine perversion umkehren oder ein
dickes und wir müssen uns fragen was ist
genau ist gelingt gut ja das ist
ungewiss
und jetzt ist natürlich gerade recht ich
wieder das tun haben sie sonst noch form
des uni gießen werden können wer 2011
des seminars noch mehr darauf dann
bekommen die frage ist können wir auch
eine vollständigkeit
also haben wir kriterien dafür
vollständigkeit des ivorischen der haupt
erreicht geht das so das muss nicht das
ziel unseres seminars sein aber mit
solchen fragen haben wir kriterien dafür
vollständigkeit zu erreichen einfach
wäre es dann wenn wir alle formen des
unmoralischen zurückführen können auf
eine gemeinsame form also eine urform
die allen anderen frauen vor geld ist
oder dem grund operation unseres denkens
und handelns gefühlen die in allen
anderen von werder weniger stark
ausgeprägt
das wäre eine möglichkeit so ein
bisschen mehr systematisch ein werk ich
habe da so eine these
ich habe da so einen kandidaten von dem
ich glaube dass der sollte
der vielheit ermöglicht eine grund
operation uns das ding ist die wie ich
glaube in form vorhanden ist - stark ich
möchte jetzt nicht vorwegnehmen
darauf kommen wir da noch zu sprechen
aber das ist natürlich auch wie alles
hier strittig und ich bitte sie auch
wenn sie an gemeinden haben die gleiche
vorzubringen und sagen stopp ich sehe es
andere diskutieren
das ist ein ziemlicher aber sehr viel
diskussion geht und ein sehr
kontroverses thema ist alle sind sehr
nah dieses thema sehr starker begriff
steine bilden wir uns befassen und diese
begriffe sind an sich schon alle
problematisch also nicht nur betreffen
sie problematisch in der welt sie
bezeichnen nicht nur sondern sind
aufgrund ihrer bedeutung schon
problematisch also zum beispiel gibt es
bösen ich denke das geht ihnen genauso
wie mir ich habe manchmal drückt die
probleme die sie begriffen als
bezeichnen
überhaupt zu verwenden ich habe das ein
bisschen skrupel und sagen das war nie
wieder etwas unangenehm werde ich diesen
begriff verwenden und so geht es ja auch
mit anderen begriffen ansprechen
das sind begriffe als solches schon
problematisch sind und nicht nur
insofern sind bestimmte phänomene in der
welt betreffen sind starke normativ
hilfe nicht alle arbeiten zb so etwas
wie einen gewissen problematischen
gegriffen wir wollen immer auch dieses
projekt ist okay jetzt habe ich eine
these haben zwar das moralisch ist kein
defizit unter defekt des moralischen wie
es solche tricks und faire ungewiss in
einigen können sondern ein ausdruck
seiner gegen die ordnung also ich glaube
dass die ganzen phänomene des
unmoralischen wenn ich etwas positives
sind nicht im sinne dass sie zu begrüßen
sind zumal sich im positiven sinn wenn
sie mir geht es in eigenständigkeit eine
eigene logik und hier und kreativ
zustand nicht mit einem defizit er
zustand ein nato- mit dem abfahren ich
glaube damit eine gegen ordnung
etabliert es hat ein positives druckt
uhr heimische struktur die wir weiter
erklären können
da konventionelle nicht in unterscheidet
nämlich es gibt private theorie ist
gesagt eben das böse automatisch um
anlagen mit moralischen das wird mit
solchen begriffen oder
trainingsgefährtin gelegt und es gibt
den perversion story des menschen
sie bedeutet das leben eine gegen morgen
eine aktive umkehrung dieser moralischen
ordnung vorgenommen ich persönlich bin
großer vertreter dieser perversion ist
er aber nicht gestehen gestehe dass auch
einiges gibt was für die überzeugendste
entspricht der grund gegen eine familie
ist der dass es unmoralisch ist immer
unserer freiheit und zwar eine
entscheidung zu zweit ist ein globales
handeln unterliegen wir nicht nur einen
fehler sind wir begehen ein fehler aber
dieser fehler ist und selbst schreibt
und dafür sind wir verantwortung
deswegen ist es nicht nur defizite
sondern ist es etwas was ich reise
ständig etwas in uns selbst unserer
aktivität und nicht nur in unserer
passive die trümmer
das ist also meine these aber darunter
diskutieren so und jetzt möchte ich mal
hier sind die bücher vorstellen also das
von pollmann diese frauen des
moralischen lasse ich mal durchgehen ist
unhandlich schau mal kurz rein das ist
dann ist es kein 1900 und 2000 zählen
das ist hier original ausgabe können sie
eine rein schauen
ich habe es auch
digital ist können sie da sich auch über
das ns system sorgen
dann muss ich ein bisschen eigenwerbung
machen hier die gründe des bösen g20 ist
ischer zu theorie des bösen m zur
einführung sie kennt nur diese junius
nehmen oder geht es eher so ein bisschen
zur sache ich weiß auch mal durchgehen
gibt es in der bibliothek und ein neues
buch ist im plan
das kommt jetzt demnächst reist und dann
lasse ich ihn auch wenn sie wohl schon
so paar kapitel zu geben zu kommen dass
man nicht im handel erschienen da geht
es auch so ein bisschen
interdisziplinäre perspektiven des bösen
also das böse in der theologie das böse
in der filmwissenschaft das lose in der
musik in solche unterdessen perspektiven
das gerät was kann ein bisschen mit
bewährung und jetzt die jetzt zur
methode bis in der standortfrage zum die
namen haben sie noch ihr inhaltliches
ich gehe jetzt in der zweiten hälfte
dieser zum methodischen zur methode
bisher
wie stelle ich mir dieses seminar vor
die alle seminare möchte ich hier
historisch systematisch vorgehen
das bedeutet und gelesenen texte also
wir lesen teilweise primär texte von
großen philosophen und philosophen die
eingespielte form des moralischen
betreffen zb immer amerika muss wenn es
jetzt um die lüge geht werden wir einen
text mehr davon handelt dass wir niemals
lügen sagt im amerika oder gar keine
stimme durch menü und jetzt überlegen
ist immer wieder lässt ihren tag nicht
die wahrheit sage es mal nicht die
wahrheit sagt dass unzählige male könnte
das hatte ich zumindest aber nicht immer
um dem anderen zu schaden sondern
manchmal um dem anderen was zu ersparen
oder um einfach mal ganzen angelegenheit
[Musik]
also gelesen texte das können klassische
texte seien von großen philosophen und
rufen oder wir lesen neuere text also
andere sächsische als englische texte
aus der sächsischen tradition aber auch
vielleicht mein kapitel aus dem buch von
pollmann und außen gut von mir da
schauen wir mal und wir wollen dann
diese jeweilige form des unfall steigen
ständig kritisieren
diskutieren und immer auch das mir ganz
wichtig anhand von beispielen
demonstrieren
das sind die leute endlich konkret wer
also wie gold aus der welt aus dem leben
phänomene auch aus dem alltag phänomene
herausgreifen als beispiele und sie hier
uns vergegenwärtigen
dann ist mir ganz wichtig dass dieses
seminar wie sie haben dieses aufbaus
dieser installation schon sehen dass
diese szene nach traditionell und
digitale zugleich ist also wir haben
eine physische präsenz und wir
transformieren diese physische präsenz
ins digitale das zeigt damit dass sie
eben ab der nächsten sitzung dann den
livestream 10 auf einem youtube kanal
des trainings gleich noch genau
ohne dass sie eben auch die ganzen
inhalte dieses seminares aufbereitet
über eine app zu könig finden und waren
wie dieses team verletzt das ist mir
ganz wichtig dass wir hier die neue
medien und ganz gezielt fruchtbar
einsetzen sie bekommt von mir im
wöchentlichen zusammenfassung der
seminar setzen also auch der heutigen
von email wenn sich eingetragen hat
nicht deiner liste und über die app von
der teilnahme absagen musste man noch zu
dem youtube kanal auf dem sie dann auch
den wald finden kannst das ist ein alter
screenshot damals hatten wir nur 55
haben
mittlerweile haben wir mit 730 problem
das ist schon mal was und wir sind
ständig am wachsen müsse man schauen
dass der ist ein kanal auf dem wir also
jede menge wir haben vielleicht über 100
videos drauf das sind tagung des videos
sind vorlesungsaufzeichnungen von
anderen professorin und fest im
vergangenen semester das sind
experteninterview musste sind wie gesagt
sind eine aufzeichnung alles mögliche
das stellen wir drauf und neuerdings
eben auch livestreams und wir sind im
recht schnell wachsender kanal und sind
sehr optimistisch dass wir eben das ist
die tausender marke knacken und damit
gehören wir zu den mittelgroßen kann
nicht immer ein zu großes andere kanäle
sind aber mit 1000 bis man als
philosophische kanal gelegt worden
aufgestellten wir tun unser möglichstes
um ein mitarbeiter nicht um hier die
1000 marke zu knacken
und dann geht es dir noch diese app wie
lukas tab die können sich jetzt schon
unterlagen mit simone des kostenlosen
app raisdorf und google store bei
einfach viel lowcost eingeben und sieht
so aus ist der lage den schirm dann gibt
es hier ein paar lügen wenn sie das
schon mal ein statistik hier drei bieter
einmal philosophie des digitalen das ist
interessiert an der enz in ihrer form
eines moralisch und ich habe noch das 7
dieses sommersemester fox erlass von
gesetzen sondern es sind die sünde und
das böse und damit rein getan dass ich
da auch noch ein bisschen mit den
blättern können wenn sie die app dann
geöffnet haben und sehen sich hier
verschiedene symbole also für jedes
seminare sind gefahr als das rote es ist
immer für unser seminar hier alle
beiträge die mit diesem symbol versehen
sind betreffen unser fühlen sich gut
merken des französischen im beruf und
dann habe ich noch eben andere sachen
trainer hier des blau ist ein ewiges
antritt
vitalität wenn sie jetzt mal auf blicken
wir hier haben sie schon den seminarplan
praktisch für die hosentasche
der ist immer aktuell also etwas
verändert würde zum thema wird es aber
besser auf diese app damit aktuell sein
schauen sie darf aber zur 1 dort finden
sie dann auch die gerne sind
zusammenfassungen dieser sitzung zum
beispiel auch der heutige neben zu
machen das ist immer so seiten im din a
4 seite und da gibt es dann auch mal
lauter legt begriffe das seien mit gen
die armee ssige verknüpfte begriffe von
denen sie dann zum einen oder anderen
mitspringen können diese sowohl hier
bedeutet dass es hier so youtube video
gibt du sollst und linken auf 4 und
jupiter können sich zwar noch videos von
einer vergangenen tagung an sind jetzt
gestern vorgestern zu ende gegangen okay
das ist damit digitale struktur haben
dazu verlangt ok dann geht es jetzt nur
zum vornamen und zwar zu den
hausarbeiten und es sind eben dieser
eigentlich können hier noch ausarbeiten
geschrieben werden aber wenn es jemand
der lehramt studiert oder so hier nicht
gut dann können wir eben nach hause bei
und geschrieben werden und würde sie
bitten wenn sie sich dann zu einem thema
interessieren rechtzeitig mit mir schon
kontakt aufzunehmen also jedes thema
sollte mit mir kurz gesprochen weil es
eben manchmal den fall dass dann eine
kandidatin kempten über irgendwas
schreibt und das passt nicht so ganz zur
bitte mit mir absprechen
entweder in einer sprechstunde oder per
e mail ein e mail heißt zu stücken wir
einfach ein paar zeilen was sie
besonders spannend finden dann kann ich
ihnen sagen nehmen sie noch das mit auf
lassen sie das weg hier gibt es gute die
transporter zurück
meistens ist
so dass man sich von der hausarbeit zu
viel vornimmt also häufig muss dann
einfach sagen machen sie das nicht mehr
lassen sie ist weg das gilt für mich
mache aber sprechen sie das mit mehr ab
ich mache ihnen aber auch noch eine
liste mit möglichen themen zu kennen ja
die hausarbeit soll dem circa 40.000
zeichen umfassen wissen zu 15 bis 16
seiten und der letzten mögliche abgabe
terminliste montag mit 21
september 2009 10 um 23 uhr 59
fragen sie die aber das schließt auch
bei die universität schließt ja immer
nur diese anwendungen und des
arbeitsalltags war das nämlich extra von
1 kommission hat sie schickt mir das
einfach per e-mail
sie brauchen es mir nicht physisch
ausgedruckt zu geben das genügt für mich
mir das ganze einfach zuschicken hans
email und als management und bietet pdf
format und geben sie in der betreffzeile
einfach haushalt form des unmoralischen
an
ich versuche also ich bin kommentare
über ganz lustig
wir kommen immer kurz vor 24
ganz minimal und bleiben an diesem tag
auch besonders lange auf um ihn
möglichst zeitnah noch
mitbestimmungsmodell zerstritten dass
sie dann wohl zu befürchten dass
irgendwas nicht angekommen ist
da das bringen wir auch einen anderen
punkt wenn es mir mal eine email
schreiben sollten und ich da nicht
gleich darauf antworte leute es nicht
besser wäre ihm endlich fertig ist sind
dann habe ich vielleicht sie leider
nicht gelesen
jetzt kann in ganz seltenen fällen
passieren nehmen sie das nicht
persönlich sondern schreiben sie mir
doch mal
ich hatte ihnen damals geschrieben ich
möchte nochmal sie daran erinnern müssen
also mich persönlich nehmen wir nicht
irgendwie mal was vergessen sollte das
kann einfach passieren wenn man viele e
mails gebraucht dann muss ich ihm sagen
müssen sie eben darauf achten dass wenn
sich dadurch krank sein sollten oder
werden sollte was nicht hoffe dass sie
dann eben dafür sorgen dass das
prüfungsamt rechtzeitig
mit einer test die kollegen dann
schriftgröße 12
haupttext stück produziert fußnoten
blocksatz 15 fahrer zeitabstand die
fußnoten einfacher zeitabstand und die
seitenzahlen bitte nicht vergessen und
maßgeblich ist dass sie den text vor der
abgabe gründlich lesen also auf
rechtschreibfehler kommasetzung ist mir
in den letzten arbeiten immer wieder
aufgefallen dass da vor solchen
unterordnung konditionen sind weil das
buch wohl geahnt dass da einfach häufig
keine kameras gesetzt worden
das wollten sie ein bisschen also ich
werde dann auch in den rückmeldungen
sind bekommen wir auch schriftliche
rückmeldung je richtung aus ein bisschen
auf eine miete art und weise ebenso
vertraut darauf hinweisen wenn ja wenn
da ein komma fehlt also da bin ich schon
recht genau
und zwar deswegen weil komma ist einfach
ganz wichtig für die strukturierung des
films sind komma strukturieren einen
text im übergeordneten 100 ordnete
gedanken schritte
und weil es der philosoph ihr besonders
auch argumentation ankommt ist mir
wichtig dass wir hier die kommandos
richtig setzen neue rechtschreibung hin
oder her aber diese kommandos setzt man
meines wissens immer noch dann in
titelblatt mit denen und da sollten sie
seien aussagekräftig titel verbindet
darüber redet man nochmal ich werde ja
auch ab und zu mögliche themen
vorstellen zum beispiel wenn wir jetzt
in seinem thema hier besonders lange
diskutieren und ich glaube da gibt es
interessante alte stunden dann werde ich
ihn die so sagen vielleicht mental
verschreibung und da können wir uns
merken und es auch so dass mehrere von
ihnen über dasselbe thema schreiben
dürfen sie müssen alle nicht dafür
sorgen dass nur eine person jetzt auf
ein thema konzern wenn jetzt eben alle
über die lüge schreiben wollen dann
dürfen auch eine religiöse schreiben
funktioniert das total interessant ist
jedoch gebe es eben neben der arbeit
einen prägnanten titel und einem extra
unternehmen das im oberdorf sind
durchaus ein bisschen provokativ sein
irgendwie zitat nehmen
geben sie ihre persönlichen
informationen an den wohn oder baulich
nicht auch er gewusst hätte dass ihr
mich nicht aber den matrikelnummer
sollte schon dabei sein auch ihre e mail
adresse
ich sehe erreichte der abgabe aber auch
nicht vergessen und dann ist es ganz
wichtig dass ich die arbeit liedern ist
auch jan ich gar nicht sagen ein
hauptteil schluss und das ist das
überhaupt ein inhaltsverzeichnis
reduzieren und das bitte nicht von hand
machen sonst gehört oder was auch immer
sie verbinden über die option
formatvorlage dass das
inhaltsverzeichnis automatisch erstellt
wird für diejenigen für die die nicht
wissen wie es geht das ist nicht schlimm
ich habe hier eine beschreibung der
beschreibung video auf youtube auf dem
fluggast kanal wo sie ganz einfach sehen
wie man das mal das ist fast wie das
heißt ein bildschirm bildaufnahmen
tinyurl.com schrägstrich hausarbeiter
1000 da kommen sie direkt zu können sich
einfach kommt direkt von video und da
habe ich das recht ausführlich das sah
das auch dann wie man nicht mehr vom mal
eine hause bevor la formation la
gegliedert sind auch ihnen wie man
inhaltlich dann mit der einleitung
vorangeht
also da kann sich die kosten werden die
folien stellen übrigens auch auf youtube
oder auf die verbindlich unter den
jeweiligen video auf youtube die folie
wird diese karte sehen und die dann auch
noch warum und stellt vielleicht ist
genau sie hier gibt es die anleitung zur
erstellung und genau also wichtig ist
eben das ist eine der leitfragen kann
die leidvolle eine lite problem und das
soll es immer in der einleitung
also was ist das schwierig war es das
für das interessante an diesem thema hat
es das philosophische interessant an der
lüge
aber solche das überhaupt nachdem
sollten sonderzeichen unmoralischen sein
geschäft
diese kurzfristig in frage aber immer
mit einem problem verbinden nicht gleich
auf die sache sich stürze sind erst mal
motivieren
was sind die gründe dafür dass wir uns
damit philosophische auseinandersetzung
gehört dass der andere disziplinen wird
lügen nicht zu den juristen
also meine arbeit und
darum sollte sagt wieder
oder sollte das nicht jedermanns eigenes
sein welches nicht stichwort moralismus
nach warum sollte mir überhaupt da so
moralisch jeder kann doch was er will
selbst wenn es in antalya
also wenn das ganze problematisieren sie
können mehrere leitfragen nur eine aber
mindestens ein und aus dieser leitfrage
ist sollte sich dann schon so ein
bisschen argumentative struktur gegeben
also ein problem an lebens immer komplex
das sollen sie zerlegen in seine
einzelnen bestandteile wie sieht das
ganze verfasst haben
das setzt natürlich voraus dass das
problem nicht so groß ist weil sie sonst
auf jährlich 1000 zeit gar nicht
behandeln können und zwar sehr sehr tief
durchdringend deswegen lieber die klappe
halten geht nicht so wie probleme
konzentrieren als ich zu viel zu tun
haben argumentative struktur ist ein
richtig guter gedanke dass mir auch ganz
wichtig und dissertanten gab es sollte
sich formal in der anlage des
inhaltsverzeichnis durch die
untergliederung widerstand
[Musik]
literaturverzeichnis können sie entweder
durch fusion oder mahnwachen weil sie in
klammern direkt nach dem zitat und der
verwaltung übernehmen durch fußnoten
zeit reinheit ich durch ihn können sie
ein kurzes zielen vergeben kpv von kants
kritik der aktie 5 ha ha für die
akademie ausgezeichnet
wie sollten sie aber auch einmal
erläuterte genau das habe ich gesagt
gedanken schritte und der schlussteil im
schlussteil nicht nochmal neues fass
aufmachen zu dem schlussteil
zusammenfassen von tieren die eingangs
gestellten leidvoll eine frische
leitfrage treffen beantworten und
vielleicht auch probleme punkte
markieren die es jetzt nicht diskutieren
konnte oder weiterführende fragen
aufwerfen aber nicht mehr beantworten
man sagt hier hätte sich jetzt noch
dieses problem gestellt und hier könnte
man noch so weiter fragen
das konnte aber im rahmen diese 40.000
zeichen nicht wenn es um die natur
verzeichnen ist alles beim anbringen und
jetzt ist nur noch eines wichtig weil
das gas bei mir damals schon das brauche
ich ihn wahrscheinlich
aber wem sie im literaturverzeichnis die
traktoren aufführen zeugen zieht wochen
wirklich verwendet haben
als es so wenn sie es möchten hinten
wieder zehn titeln und ich findet er
aber die verweise auf die literaturen
haupttext nicht dann weiß ich nicht wo
sie jetzt einen text darauf sich bezogen
haben das heißt ich weiß nicht wo ihre
eigenleistung besteht die rezeptions
leistung besteht also nicht mehr am ende
zu sagen auf diese 10 tmg gezogen ich
muss schon wissen wo sie sich darauf
also dass darauf achten also wenn sie
was eben angeben müssen sie im haupttext
sich darauf bezogen dass so können es
ist ungefähr endlich kann orientieren
nach diesem schema so kann es auch
anders man muss halt ein anderes wie es
merkt stelle ich auch noch auf die
ändern
es muss ein heiliges jetzt komme ich
noch zum brisanten thema
jetzt wird zu langsam kommen wir jetzt
vom malen wieder zu inhaltlichen zum
humor wehre mich jetzt über das formale
die inhaltlich
zitierens mit dem haus und eine quelle
wikipedia oder sonst sind nicht durch
wissenschaftliche autorinnen und autoren
verantwortenden texten die sie im netz
finden
das heißt jetzt nicht dass sie nicht im
internet suchen sollten natürlich auch
ständig habe ich an meine ganzen
schulbilder computer bräuteln über diese
aber regierung zu wikipedia ist auch
ganz toll den ersten zugriff
nur eben soll das der erste schritt
zahlen nicht der letzte sollte das alles
am ausgangspunkt möglichen ausgangs
probleme und mit peter finden sie auch
gute literaturverweise und nur das ist
dann so ein bit system dann kommen sie
mit einem begriff auf dem nächsten
stolpert anregen
aber es sollte nicht der endpunkt es
soll neben wissenschaftlichen text
mehrere anziehen
wikipedia artikel sind eben von ganz
verschiedenen autoren verfasst worden
die auch nicht namentlich genannt werden
müssen alles zur höhe
ich selbst würde dort auch mit und
schreibt es nicht unter dem klarnamen
und sie wissen auch nie wer jetzt für
welchen teil dieses artikels zu
verantwortlich ist das können sie will
um ihre kunst und in der version
so können sie ein
für mich zitiert also neben diesen aus
ganz gut aber zitiert sie nicht gemacht
was sie zitieren können zeigten jetzt
ist im etablierten internet enzyklopädie
in philosophischer hauptmann kennt
jemand für ihn eine internet
enzyklopädie in englisch die
philosophisch besonders relevant ist
die schreiben hier sei in kürze das
tempo der selber als er fragte hier auch
für das genaueste parteien cvp die
philosophie
[Musik]
das ist ein ganz ganz zitierfähige der
seite finden sie hier nach englisch die
wirklich hoch qualitativen beiträge ins
team
ich weiß das gibt ihm orientierung mir
sowas
schauen sie mal dann haben sie zitieren
es gibt da noch die ip die internet
enzyklopädie und es gibt vielleicht auch
deutsche
da sollten sie will ich darauf achten da
müssen sie ein gespür dafür entwickeln
ob das wirklich im etablierten autoren
und autoren verfasst als akademische
so und jetzt kann man vom format direkt
wieder zurück zum inhalt des seminars
jetzt geht's zum moralischen jetzt geht
es ums platzieren und das wäre eine form
die wir aufnehmen könnten lackieren
aber das ist ein spezieller soweit ich
platt gern das ganz spannend mit
richtiger ich sie mal fragen und der wm
bereits genannte form des unmoralischen
würden sie denn jetzt plagiat fassen
lüge ebenso wie light night gut gut
ich denke es in mischungen missachtung
jahr nicht als sie sehen wir können
sogar da bin ich jetzt gerade
aufgekommen wir können manche phänomen
zurückführen auf eine kombination
verschiedener form zwar nicht so dass
jetzt die jedes plakat nur der monstranz
das mag ein grund sein ich gönne es den
anderen nicht in zu zitieren
chris muss der anordnung kommen zu
beziehen lass dich auch noch spannend
findet die selbst täuschen die selbst
täuschen wir uns selbst im plagiat genau
gericht deswegen schaue ich auch hier
vermeiden sie nun beabsichtigte klappt
ja auch ich glaube nicht dass wir den
meisten fällen bewusst plagiiert uns
natürlich sagt auch dass jetzt ihr
sparen diesen bezug weil das ist jetzt
kein frau müller verpasst wurde
das schreibe ich jetzt ein bisschen
anders und dann merkt man ja das habe
ich auf dieser seite nur zitiert und
jetzt möchte ich mal so tun als ob auch
was wir selbst zeigen haben ansonsten
könnten die motivation groß aber ich
glaube dass es nur in seltensten fällen
so ist und ich glaube dass man das
unbeabsichtigte in letzer hinsicht
unberechenbar aber eben dass man sich
dann selbst täuscht das ändert sich
etwas vormacht
sagt ich hab den habe ich ja schon
sortiert und habe ich direkt davor
zitiert
das nein eigentlich auch das nächste wo
ich mir jetzt noch akzeptieren könnte
und den klassischen der einfachheit weg
sie geben immer so eine begründung da
anlagen also könnte zeit oder ein
anderer punkt ist sie haben damals
gelesen von dem auto nach motoren und
das leuchtet jetzt so ein dass sie dann
wird man denken das konsumieren
das ist ja mein gedanke sie kennen sich
ein gedanke so verinnerlicht ist es auch
hier gedanken und ich muss dazu sagen es
ist philosoph problematisch von
gedanklichen eigentum zu sprechen die
philosophische gedanken gehören
niemanden werden alle noch niemand
nur das problem ist wenn sie eben dann
im rahmen der hauser weiter verschreiben
dann muss ich eben dann bewerben und
ihre leistung jetzt und
leistungserfassung das heißt dass weder
eigentlich gar nicht mehr richtig fusion
bestehen zu können wir haben beschreiben
das muss man selbstkritisch sagt es ist
jetzt eben eine gewisse formale struktur
des philosophierens die durchaus eine
gewisse oberflächlichkeit hat aber nur
sowas leistungserfassung möglich man
kann sie
streit um überhaupt die
leistungserfassung philosophie ist dass
gute frage aber im rahmen dieses dieser
vorgabe die wir leben hier haben die
institution muss ich eben schon
unterscheiden kann wo ihre leistungen
nicht und deswegen müssen sie schon wie
so etwas wie die herkunft eines
gedankens nachvollziehen auch wenn der
gedanke ihn dann so sehr ans herz
gewachsen sein sollte das probieren
ist müssen sie ins tal wo sie den
angriffen hat man gespürt ich gemacht
vor 500 jahren noch 400 jahre das
niemanden gestellt da gab es den vorwurf
des abschreibens nicht behauptet und hat
man sich eine tradition gefügt hat sie
vor ort ist und immer wieder kamen dann
durch eine neue hinzu aber er hat da
niemand geschrieben
so auch hier kommt es jetzt verlieren
diese gedanken des modernen auto riss
des urheberrechts das ja dass der
herkunft der den gibt es erst seit
ungefähr anderthalb jahren so mit diesem
gedanken des genies romantik in dieser
zeit tritt erst auf der feste stellen
wenn sie zum beispiel artikel texte
lesen über medizinische plakate muss
sich etwas lesen und verteilen
griechischen vergleichen wo hatte jetzt
abgeschrieben
ständig ohne verweis einfach aktion
gehalt kann man das gedankengut
gemeingut
das ist jetzt eben jemals und wie können
sie solche plagiate
bildnis ist ihr seine eigene meinung
bevor sich leicht dass sie kommt der
literatur konsultieren
also überlegen sind mit welcher
motivation gehe ich jetzt hier an warum
zusätzlich mir jetzt gerade die lüge vor
da haben sie schon einen gedanken
vorliegen der eigenständig expliziert
sie dem grund ihres interesses für
dieses thema
da haben sie schon eigene gedanken damit
existieren sie den primär text und
machen sie sich anmelden also nicht
gleich auf die sekundärliteratur
verdienen sie erstmal mindestens zb für
machen erkannt geht mit dem originaltext
ganz gründlich studieren existieren dazu
und dann auch das herkommt der ritter
und wenn sie eine eigene these ideen.de
getan
damit können sie zu sein kommt der
literatur übergeben in dem sind diese
nutzen zur weiteren vertiefung ergänzung
aber auch zur diskussion
und wenn sie der these haben können sie
diese aus andere thesen in der
sekundärliteratur diskutieren
kritisieren dass ich könnte sagen
frau meier sagt dass darüber der stimme
ich aber nicht zu ich stimme herrn
müller zu besetzen
so ging es dann kreative der sekunde
so sollten auch sekundärliteratur im
idealfall verwendet
so jetzt zimmer ein nicht durch und
macht mich ziemlich gleich und gelassen
haben sie noch fragen sollen noch immer
irgendwas was mir nicht ganz klar war
reden hanselmann irgendwelchen punkten
hier noch fehlen oder rückfragen sehen
was nicht klar wie sieht's aus
das ist ein sehr spannendes thema
schwindel und ist ein sehr aktuelles
thema und das nachdem das wichtig ist
dass sie wie man sich kritische gießen
beim beschriften außengrenze
ich verfahre hinzunehmen und da muss man
menschen durchaus ein bisschen recht
geben erkenntnisse
also erkennt man nur dann wäre mit einer
interesse dahinter
meine these ist in geometrische linien
wieder auf zeit und sagt dass das böse
das sind eigentlich bestimmt
machtinteressen springen hatten ihn
schon eigentlich eine andere moral
gerade wieder begründet mitte möchte
gegen die moral haben mit ihren es aber
doch freilich gerade journalist und die
man sagte dass er den begriff des bösen
so verwendet werden verbindet zeigt dass
sie in den moralischen als ich glaube
wir kommen aus dem rheinischen aus und
zwar deswegen können wir frei gewesen
sind die von ihrer handlungen zur
verantwortung gezogen werden können und
sollen und auch letztendlich möchten wir
möchten uns als individuen in dieser
welt und damit muss liefern hier gehen
dass wir für alles was wir tun was du so
ist tun verantwortlich sind und dass wir
uns eben
auch mit normativen den lippen des guten
die auf das unmoralische begreifen
lassen und das soll jetzt auch das
schlusswort gewesen sein
ich wünsche dir alles gute und wir sehen
und dann in der nächsten sitzung